da fällt mir ein haben sie das
eigentlich gehört die afd wird wohl bald
befördert vom rechtsextremen prüfer zum
rechtsextremen verdachtsfall
glückwunsch hochverdient dann könnte der
verfassungsschutz die partei mit
geheimdienstlichen mitteln überwachen
für die afg sachsen anhalt wurde der
traum gerade war bei der bundes partei
steht die entscheidung wohl kurz bevor
deswegen hat die parteispitze um der
beobachtung vielleicht doch noch zu
entgehen last minute eine wirklich super
lustige mitteilung rausgehauen hier
zitat als rechtsstaatspartei bekennt
sich die afg vorbehaltlos zum deutschen
staatsvolk als der summe aller personen
die die deutsche staatsangehörigkeit
besitzt und dann kommt unabhängig davon
welchen ethnisch kulturellen hintergrund
jemand hat
und ich dachte karneval fällt aus er ist
klar die fdp hat sich noch nie für den
ethnisch kulturellen hintergrund von
mitbürgern interessiert die sehen nur
den menschen und sie legen als einzige
den finger in die eigentliche corona
wunde
ich bin ein sehr freiheitsliebender
mensch 30 am donnerstag vom zweiten
sogenannten lockdown gehört habe an der
stelle wieder die bemerkung warum
sprechen wir in deutschland deutsch
sprechen wir nicht herum spricht wenig
bravo lockdown heißt in deutschland
immer noch skis runter oder so das sind
probleme freunde selbstverständlich um
den verfassungsschutz ein bisschen zu
helfen verachten weite teile der afd die
parlamentarische demokratie und ihre
institution aktuelles beispiel die
rechtspopulisten feuern wirklich aus
allen rohren gegen trommelwirbel die
briefwahl ja kommt ihnen bekannt vor
oder meine wie erbärmlich ist das denn
abgelegte trump ideen klauen bei briefen
kann man generell bedenken haben weil
das natürlich auch das einfallstor der
manipulation ist wer sagt denn nicht
dass mit genügend kriminelle energie
sich briefwahl dokumente fälschen lassen
weil sie und das wollen sie mit ihrem
beschluss einer pandemischen
gesundheitslage weil sie briefwahl
durchführen wollen um den größten wahl
betrifft dieses landes im nächsten jahr
neu zu führen
wussten sie gar nicht corona ist nur
erfunden worden um die afg durch
briefwahl zu bescheißen das heißt die
chinesen haben im auftrag von merkel in
wohin ich weiß es doch auch nicht
kann es sein dass die partei jetzt schon
an der bullshit briefwahl legende
gestrickt weil sie ahnen dass die
kommenden wahlen für sie vielleicht
nicht so dolle laufen
ich meine wenn das so wäre dürfte man
das ja in keinem fall laut sagen brief
hat nicht so viele anhänger um flachen
land da sitzen aber genau die wähler
regio die kfd wer das heißt die kritik
an der briefwahl entzündet sich an der
erwartung dass dann die wahlergebnisse
für die afg schlechter ausfallen ja ja
hab ich gerade ja gesagt das war ja echt
blöd von mir kann man das noch mal
drehen
auch wurde schon gesendet schade schade
er sollte man die gesamtpartei fd
beobachten ist schwierig ich finde es
wirklich schwierig denn damit hilft man
ihnen natürlich wieder beim guten alten
opfermythos ist eine ganz schwierige
frage klären wir am besten vor gericht
herzlich willkommen zu
das heute show schlussplädoyer mit star
anwalt till reiners hohes gericht
der verfassungsschutz fragt gibt es bei
der afg zitat gewichtige anhaltspunkte
für verfassungsfeindliche bestrebungen
das muss man sich mal auf der zunge
zergehen lassen vielleicht anhaltspunkte
unter welchem steine haben sie die
letzten sechs jahre verbracht ist die
afg extremistisch dazu hier beweisstück
wenn man ganz genau hinsieht erkennt man
ich bin trotzdem gegen die beobachtung
afd telefongespräche abhören was soll
das bringen wenn ich schon rassistisch
sind wenn die kameras an sind wie sollen
wir da erst reden wenn die aus sind ich
glaube nicht dass der herr camp tv neuen
rolle spielt und danach seine frau
anrufen sagt hey schatz
ja ich habe gerade wieder für die
tagesschau nazi gegeben hat sozial
extrem sage ich mal
danach sehen wir uns gleich bei unserer
kuchen aktion für rumänische
waisenkinder gyan 1 0x zuerst auf
ernsthaft wozu v-leute in der afg
anwerben
dann gibt der staat afd mitgliedern geld
damit die dem verfassungsschutz sagen
was in der zeitung steht oder was die
afg hat sich doch gerade von ganz
alleine ins abseits und dann rechts
jedoch nicht dabei vor krone haben die
aufmerksamkeit gekriegt weil sie immer
nur laut nein schreien wollte
geflüchtete aufnehmen müsste man nicht
mehr fürs klima tun
jetzt fragt man die afd wie ist eure
corona strategie und sie sagen und dann
merkt auch der letzte das ist gar keine
antwort ist es ist ja wirklich so ich
mein welcher meinung hatte in die afg zu
corona alle vor allem was wir wissen
geht von dem virus eine höhere
ansteckungsgefahr und ein größeres
mortalitätsrisiko aus als von der
gewöhnlichen grippe
es ist keine epidemie wie pest oder
cholera sondern ist eine verhältnismäßig
leichte grippe ein impfstoff der mit
deutschem steuergeld gefördert und von
einem mainzer unternehmen maßgeblich
entwickelt wurde ist für deutsche kaum
verfügbar
ja und ich hinterfrage ob diese impfung
tatsächlich sinnvoll wenn also es muss
ein augenmerk zum beispiel auf das
konsequente tragen von mund- und
nasenschutz massen gelegt werden das ist
das symbol
der freiheitsberaubung und der
antidemokratischen unterdrückung es
fehlt nur noch dass mannheim corona zum
offiziellen kurs erklären ja wie denn
jetzt mit jedem afd interview zu corona
rutschen die umfragewerte weiter in den
keller
ich glaube bernd du kannst es noch
toppen corona ist vorbei ist und krone
wieder woanders großartig liebe
geschworenen die afg muss unbedingt mehr
raum bekommen sich selber zu zerlegen
mein vorschlag der verfassungsschutz
beobachtet irgendwas anderes die sterne
vögel sich selber keine ahnung und die
afg beobachten einfach weiter wir von
der heute show für umsonst an ihren
stimmen ja nicht also von ihren gebühren
liebe afd wählerinnen und wähler
deswegen an dieser stelle einfach mal
danke keine weiteren fragen
ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines auto
bieten
einfach anklicken macht's gut
los los du scheiße fährt haye